[Music]
today all unstick the football we have a
fun will bring it is draft week we have
made it it is here it is almost time and
the show is gonna be fun three trades
little F up your mock draft I don't
think that's the official wording but
that's what we're doing as someone who's
already filed their final mock draft
this is my nightmare
this is my worst case scenario is a
trade happens right now and I'll look
wrong because I don't have time to redo
the damn thing and then also in his
sleeper time you're going to sleepers
from each of your favorite hosts on
stick to football that is Matt Miller
Melo and Connor Rogers don't forget you
can leave your draft on draft questions
right here if you're watching in the
Bleacher Report app and you should be
leave those drafts on draft questions in
the comments will answer some at the end
of the show and guys speaking of the
Bleacher Report app make sure that baby
is updated for Thursday night because
the draft kicks off at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Time updating right now hello myself
Connor and Adam the man left code will
be breaking down every pic from night
one night two and most of day three as
long as our voices and internet hold up
mellow and Connor welcome to the show
I'm just gonna go I was ready to do the
whole show today the man is a little
excited if you can't tell it is draft
week everybody's sweating as we submit
our final mock drafts and just to make
them even worse we're gonna kick this
thing off with some wild trades Connor
you get to kick this one off man because
we are this is your worst case scenario
if you're a mock draft or for a living
you know that people are going to
Twitter no matter what wrecking your
mock drafts I don't know if you guys saw
I'm actually donating $100 for every pic
I get wrong in my mock draft this year
to copa90 no relief so watch I'll go
over 32 this year but Connor this is the
one thing that will throw things off
trades in the first round especially in
the top 10 and you have a fun one to get
things going here when I do this guy's I
look at what we always view as layup
picks for all of our mock trap Mondays
this goes back to last August and I
think with us right now we have looked
at the Philadelphia Eagles for quite
some time and just gone whoever's making
the Pitt gun Justin Jefferson sure why
not
let's have a little fun and say the
Eagles desire a little bit more they
want one of those top three receivers
and they are willing to pay the price to
get their pick of the bunch they are
gonna call the Cleveland Browns yes the
analytics focus Cleveland Browns making
their debut draft this new front office
and they're gonna offer the Browns the
21st overall pick their second round
pick 53 and 127 overall so those are
three picks they get to come up to ten
and get the pick of their wide receivers
I don't think one will be off the board
at this point of the draft I think
something mat that you and I have even
talked about this week on the left go
show is this feels like it might be a
move for Jerry Judy just because he's
the most Pro ready of the bunch with his
route running ability maybe they like
Henry rug speed maybe they just like CB
lamb overall but when you look at this
for the Browns that we're not convinced
that the tackle they want is gonna fall
to them they want more picks to add
maybe they'd like a Josh Jones or Azra
Cleveland later on in the first round
instead but Howie Rosamond making a
splash that wouldn't surprise me one bit
no not at all and especially for a team
it feels like they're trying to keep
that Super Bowl window alive you have
Carson Wentz they bolstered that D line
through free agency ad Darius slay now
you need to get Carson Wentz a number
one receiver who will not drop things
like Nelson Aguilar and I think with the
Browns there's a lot of buzz about them
trading back maybe they feel like they
can get a tackle like and Ezer Cleveland
later in the first round can I just go
ahead and say if they do that it will be
the worst pick of the first round I
don't even know the other 31 pick [ __ ]
it's not good to go to the Browns they
took the Cleveland off the front of the
jersey to put it on the back of his
basically the front we'll never know
you'll have to ask him when he gets
drafted Mel alright you're crazy
Trey not even crazy your trade that
would wreck your mug I'm gonna one-up
you guys Connor because the Eagles are
coming out and they're gonna target a
receiver
I think the Raiders are gonna do the
exact same but they're gonna trade all
the way up to the fourth pick overall I
think the Giants are talking a lot to a
lot of teams about who to trade for I
think maybe we can see some teams trade
up to number three and get their quarter
and then I think the Dolphins stay pad
at number five but I do think we're
gonna see teams start to try to trade up
and get into a position to take these
receivers
well the Raiders have the picks to go
out and say you know what we want our
guy whether it's rugs or it's lamb they
can move up and get them why not move
all the way up to number four and grab
your go-to receiver in this office I
think we've just assumed if they go up
to four would be for a quarterback so I
like them with like you know what we'll
just go up to four and get a wide
receiver distance like Julio Jones I
think they could target a quarterback
too but I wouldn't be surprised if we
see the Raiders move up and with all the
talk of the Giants trying to move down
or even if you're the Raiders and you
know the Giants are trying to move down
because they want Isaiah Simmons move up
there and taking yeah I Connor what are
your thoughts on this before I hop in
and smash it all to pieces
well I know Matt you're gonna smash it
all the pieces from the Raiders side so
I'll take the Giants side here being in
the New York New Jersey area I love it
for the Giants number one I think you
still get one of the top four tackles
with that 12th overall pick and even if
you don't a really good player is going
to slide to that spot and then you look
at the real what they added here number
19 guys I think that's a spot for them
to take somebody like Patrick Queen in
this area so you need help on defense
and yes the Giants they need pass-rush
health I don't know you know what the
pass rushers will look like at 19
because i think caleb on Chaisson is
gone by that point but you're looking at
adding the best cover linebacker in the
draft in Queen while you already upgrade
to offensive line at 12 having more
picks for Dave gentlemen something he
might not be used to because he never
trades down would be a really really
good thing if he knew how to spend them
I really thought you were gonna say
having more picks for Dave gentlemen
might not be a good thing because he's
not good at drafting okay let's just go
in on Dave this week that's basically
the the undertone of this entire show so
the only thing is you guys had somewhat
rate up for a wide receiver Connor has
the ego smote up Melo has the Raiders
going up receivers have not
traditionally guys draft in the first
round produced that well that is not
gonna stop me from doing the same
even though I didn't have you guys are
gonna do it so I have the Broncos
trading up to number seven overall to
get Jerry Judah the Carolina Panthers
move out of that spot because they're a
team that has a lot of needs they don't
have to pick someone at seven they move
back to fifteen pick up a third a fourth
and a 2021 second overall pick and I
believe at that spot fifteen overall you
can get Javon Kinlaw who might be a
target at seven so it's funny because we
there's this huge movement right now in
football off don't trade upper receiver
don't track the receiver early it never
works out most of the best receivers in
football work second-round picks or
later and we all have someone coming up
for one of the premier receivers in this
class this receiver group is just too
special to sit around and wait and say
oh man I hope I get one of these three
guys or even a Justin Jefferson like I
honestly I could see all four of those
guys go in top ten I think they're top
ten talent when you look at what they're
doing there's just so much depth in this
class that for a long time we said oh
move them down the board there's a lot
of good receivers there are four very
special receivers and I do think teams
like the Eagles or the Raiders they're
going to be moving up to try to get
their guy at receiver that's how I feel
as well when I look at this guys we
could spend all day talking about how we
like the second round or the second tier
when you look at KJ handler speed Jalen
rhaegar another explosive guy
Denzel Mims a bigger body size and speed
kind of player Michael Pittman T Higgins
above the rim kind of players we like
all of those guys but let's call it like
we see it they are not in the same class
as Jerry Judy CD lamb Henry rugs there's
a reason for that and if you want the
premium guys and I think we go back to
this class a lot AJ Green Julio Jones
those guys were premium picks for a
reason and I think we're gonna see the
same thing with CD lamb I think we're
gonna see the same thing with Jerry Judy
now Henry rugs there's a little more
risk there but with his speed and his
hands as long as he gets in the right
place he'll be a number one wide
receiver as well
John Ross got drafts of what ninth
overall and he wasn't nearly the
prospect that we see with Henry rugs or
these other two guys so I I really I do
think we're gonna see receivers come off
the board early in this draft class just
like we expected from the very beginning
of this thing
yeah those are our three trades that
would wreck the mock drafts you can
check out all of our final mock drafts
this week on Twitter mine will be the BR
app at mellow at Connor J Roger so I'm
gonna make sure these guys get their
final mocks at big boards Connor posted
it well I'm you know I'm waiting until
like okay you know I want to see the
trades that come down those final mock
drafts will be on Twitter from the guys
and of course check out our draft
coverage this weekend all right let's
check out a I love going back to these
gridiron hikes episodes because it's
like a stroll down memory lane we're
gonna go back in time just a little bit
to a post Super Bowl gridiron heist
episode that I know will make our Kansas
City Chiefs fan over here a little
mellow very very happy
good baccarat down hats really means a
lot to get my own farewell my dad is
starting extreme good iron Heights hello
well you live it we're on to one other
thing I'm Oliver luck lol because
everyone's been moving recently the
charger Eddie would I like to Hulu I'll
do it I'll move I don't think about you
as much as you think I do I didn't know
I was moving we now own the town where
our iron Heights is extreme everyone
calm down this will blow over where
should I go here here yeah Jason we need
drew I save myself to give up today's
episode of stick the football is brought
to you by a Playstation I actually just
picked up a ps4 to play the show because
I miss Kansas City Royals baseball so
badly
this game has incredible graphics it's
like you're really at the game only
things missing and ice cold beer insert
sponsor right here on the PlayStation
Network and challenged me to a game I'll
be online nearly 24/7 after the
craziness of draft week my prospect my
road to the show prospect 24 home runs
before the all-star break but I'm
surprised you didn't tell everybody
about all your wants odo home run tell
us all I've heard out for like the last
week the man 1 Soto
probably my favorite player in baseball
not a sleeper he's but we're gonna run
through our draft sleepers I Connor
sitting over the Mets fan it's like yeah
let's talk more about Juan Soto guys
really appreciating that let's get into
our sleepers of this year's draft we
each picked two you're a fantasy
football player you might want to take
some notes for some deep dives but Melo
you're gonna start us off you actually
got one office one defense who is your
guy on offense my guy on offense is
Colby Parkinson the big tight end out of
Stanford I was very high on this guy one
year ago I thought he would develop into
kind of a go-to receiver at Stanford
quarterback problems kind of struggled
there held him back a little bit but I
do think this is a guy
who can't go over the middle who can't
get up the seem very athletic tied in
and like I said six foot seven huge
catch radius if you are a fantasy
football guy I think that you won't have
to draft him but he's a name to keep in
mind when you're looking at later rookie
tight ends I think he can be very
productive obviously in the right system
not much of a blocker I think that's
what's gonna push him to day three he's
got the great size but not very physical
on that inline tight end position this
guy was gonna come in and be a huge slot
receiver tight in prospect but I think
he can catch a lot of balls in his
rookie here big guy hard to guard yeah I
like that call Melo when you look at
Parkinson a former five-star player and
maybe the production never translated to
that at Stanford but I still think he
has enough talent to be a productive NFL
tight end I'm gonna go with a guy that
has been productive when healthy and
that's Rico Dowdle from South Carolina
somebody that had to be in a bit of a
platoon this year with Tavian Feaster
but when you look at Dowdle a power
runner 511 213 pounds enough speed with
a four or five 440 very explosive jumps
with that 38 vertical 127 broad this is
a guy that could stick his foot in the
ground as you see there and go but he
really knows how to finish runs that's
what I like about him a lot so when you
look at daddle is he gonna be in this
class with cam makers and even Darren's
in Evans Zach Moss no he's not because
he's banged he's been banged up through
his four years at South Carolina but
when you watch the first month of film
from his senior season this year when he
was healthy he was a quietly very very
impressive running back in the SEC so I
think Dowdle will be a valued a three
pick if you take him as a backup to
spell your starter every now and then I
like both your picks but let's put some
razzle-dazzle on this and here's someone
that I always do this and then all my
friends still my fantasy picks I'm
actually tracking this player and that
is Antonio Gibson from Memphis love them
I don't know if I should call them a
running back and say we're a wide
receiver
he's an offensive weapon is what he has
six-foot 228 pounds he ran a 4-3 nine to
the 40-yard dash he scored 13 touchdowns
in college on 77 touches that is not a
lot of production you could put him in
the slot you could throw him the ball
you'd be great a jet sweeps underneath
routes I actually don't know that he has
the hips to be an NFL receiver he was a
running back in high school I'd like to
get him the ball back in that area you
see him high point he's just wrong this
is a lot like Jalen Hurd was last year
coming out of Baylor played a little
running back they're moving him to wide
receiver a full time I think Gibson
someone you're gonna have to watch the
development arc we're gonna see him
transition and translate a little bit
slower than some of the other rookies
but what he brings to the table as a
runner receiver and returner
is special so if he gets on an offense
where they know how to use guys in space
scheme touches Antonio Gibson is going
to be one of my favorite players from
offense in the stretch yeah when they
finally gave him the ball running back
he was very productive in that last game
not a lot of carries but it will be
interesting to see like you said
tracking him see where he's going to go
because he could be a hidden gym just
buried on that Memphis depth chart that
is surprisingly very deep defense for my
next guy though making those gopher fans
happy like Matt likes to do I'm going
with their linebacker edge prospect here
Carter Coughlin I really like Coughlin
he's that Swiss Army knife type guy
could be an edge rusher could be your
middle linebacker he's a little bit of
do-it-all that Kyle van Noy that Zack
bond mold that a lot of people are
wanting this is a guy that can do it he
won't have to be drafted in the first
round I really think that after seeing
him at the Senior Bowl and what Carter
Coughlin can do
he is a utility knife like so many
linebackers in this class I mean it's
not just Isaiah Simmons there are a lot
of guys in this class that can be that
athletic and do a lot of different
things in your defense this screams
Patriots pick yes means he's probably
gonna be a dolphin with Flores but I
like it and I think that he's a guy that
can fit in any defensive system he's a
poor man Zack bond yeah yeah I would
agree with that but I I don't think the
gap between them is huge he could be you
know Clay Matthews Kyle van Noy type guy
but you're probably gonna get him in
around five or six guys we have not had
much to talk about with this quarterback
class on day three this year it feels
like we've talked about obviously burrow
to the day to guys of course with Eason
from Hertz but when you look at day
three of this class maybe Anthony Gordon
at times maybe Nate Stanley at times I'm
gonna go with my favorite day three
quarterback here
that is James Morgan of FIU and when you
look at Morgan's career it's been a long
one started at Bowling Green and it was
a bit of a rollercoaster had to transfer
to FIU but his last two seasons there
have been super super impressive he is a
big bodied passer that can move a little
bit listen he's not exactly going for
three on that run but when you watch the
guy throw the ball down the field that's
what matters to me at the next level
ensure the mechanics at times are all
over the place but the arm talent is
spectacular and I think if you get him
in an NFL system where they can tailor
calm him down
work on those mechanics and make him a
little bit more accurate this is the guy
on day three in the quarterback class
that I would take a swing for the fences
for fourth fifth round kind of range
obviously to say I have Morgan ranked as
the first of the day three quarterbacks
because of know the level of competition
wasn't great but the arm talents there
there's enough athleticism something to
build on again in a in a pretty bad day
three quarterback class write my final
sleeper one Jennings at Tennessee I do
not care that Conor can run a faster
40-yard dash in this man for 72 I know
it's not great but he has to be the most
physical player in the 2020 draft class
just consistently beasting defensive
backs at the top of his routes to him at
63 215 he just plays violin if you've
ever seen someone play mad
it's him like nope running through you
running through you can't I will stiff
arm you it's just it's like me playing
football with my six-year-old like I'm
just running you over don't get in my
way I mean he plays football I could
tide him you can see him right there he
looks a lot bigger than what he's listed
at he plays more physically too I think
that he is a guy that when he gets the
ball in his hands he's pretty damn scary
I'll tell you in that number 15 that's
Abby Marsh look right there after the
catch right I mean it's like I'm not
saying he's gonna be Anquan Boldin but
it's like watching Anquan Boldin you
know the caller yeah he plays faster
more physically you know that physical
type of receiver put him somewhere where
he can run some braking routes crossing
routes where he can just post up on
these smaller defensive backs in the NFL
and I think my man is gonna have some
fun let us know who your sleepers are
again drop them in the comments below
we're gonna hop in there during this
little grid art heist 2019
draft look back at our one of our
favorite classes that we've evaluated so
far I'm so excited for career day I may
look good BK what a traditional
workplace what skills do you have office
maybe we'll be in touch maybe we won't
it's all a big secret beaker
Sam just showing the Cardinals the
Raiders are a great organization we're
gonna burn to the ground man that's why
a great bit really works so just by
looking at you I think you're definitely
Broncos quarterback aterial sir that's a
mom still I like that it's tall every
year this hurts my feelings
hello I'm Mel Kiper and I have ranked
the children ever mess with the Mannings
on career day I'm so excited for
football season to get back so we can
get the gridiron Heights
take on the Tony Khan Yannick and gawk
wait Twitter fight
who's happening Monday morning I'm gonna
take I've met both people I'm gonna take
Yannick over Tony who does run a
wrestling league but I don't think once
anything to do with an NFL defensive end
no I definitely all right we have some
draft on draft questions that you
submitted during the show our amazing
producers have been putting them in
plugging them in so we're gonna take
three draft on draft questions the first
one here from Spencer Vance over the top
three wide receivers who could be the
biggest bust this is the great thing I'm
being the hostess show I get to punt to
you guys oh yeah yeah plenty to say I
will defer I'll go first and I don't
mind saying it - I love these three top
end receivers but I think if we're gonna
see one of them bust I think it's gonna
be Henry rugs I love what Judy can do
and how well he runs
routes I love his hands I think those
are proven things in Sidi lamb I love
that he can catch the ball in traffic
and what he does after the catch with
Henry rugs he's really fast and that's
gonna be really good but is it good
enough because like we said John Ross
was really fast
and we've seen really fast guys speed
helps in football I don't think it's the
end-all be-all in football though you
have to be able to do a lot afterwards
and rugs can but if I have to say one of
them is gonna be a bust
I think it's gonna be Henry rug so I
ignore my this one I was like Conor jump
in but like Ted gano hung around the NFL
for like 12 years because he was fast
so I like that I'm gonna just go and
jump so I think rugs is the one who can
last the longest even if they're not
good because he's fat he's gonna be a
special teamer for right like he's at
least gonna be in the league forever I'm
gonna take C D lamb because my biggest
concern and again I love C D lamb top 12
overall player huge fan even though he
would talk well helmet vocal organs he
can't I have never seen him at least
beat press coverage I'm not saying he
can't almost do it I want backup
it's just will he be able to acclimate
make that transition if I worry about
anything
it's will he be able to separate in the
NFL because he had trouble doing it at
times in the big 12 which not good at
defense that conference so if you're
making me pick one it would be C D this
is the rare draft on draft question
where you get a different answer from
every host it's because there we go Judy
here and listen this is not easy to pick
amongst these three so the two reasons I
came up with why Jerry Judy could be a
bust and I do not expect this to happen
is one with the slender frame he has
injuries could be a problem at the next
level number two he has the worst hands
of the three rugs has the best hands of
the three he has one of the best her
operates in entire country C D lamb very
very close to him those guys have elite
hands jerry judy has below average hands
right now guys so listen and those that
such reaches right there of why I think
the guy could be a bus but if I have to
come up with something that's it I hope
when people clip this out and it ends up
on freezing cold takes you put the whole
context of the question yes
right exactly in two years there will be
a clip out of the three of us saying CD
lamb can't beat press coverage okay get
the whole damn thing in there please all
right second draft on draft question
from D man 84 who would wait would you
that's that that's not work would you be
willing to bet that someone takes a big
risk on Jordan love say he goes top 15
so would you be willing to be the sub
one there we go
who takes Jordan love I can't read would
you take Jordan over the top 15 would I
take him in the top 15 yes and I think
that would be surprising because I have
been hard on him but you have to risk it
for the biscuit every once in a while
and I think with Jordan love he's such a
dynamic player that he might be one of
the best quarterbacks in the league in
five years or he might be out of the
league in five years but I think you
have to take that chance and say he
could be great we need great we don't
need ya above average
we don't need Justin Herbert to win a
Super Bowl we need greatness so if I'm
taking a quarterback top 15 and I don't
have Joe Burrell I don't have to uh you
bet your ass that Jordan Love's gonna be
the guy I'm taking man this is a really
tricky one
I would not move into the top 15 for him
but if I was standing pat I would feel
comfortable taking him which is a coward
strategy I don't care I'm not confident
and that's where I'm selling the farm
for him this isn't where I'm going up
for deshaun Watson or you know I didn't
feel this way about my homes at the time
I'd be lying if I said I did but going
up for my home's I'm not on that level
but I think if you're sitting there in
the top 15 I think that's why we put
into the Colts so often before they move
their draft pick guys it felt like one
of those things where they could take
him develop them before they move to
their pick and not have to risk anything
else to get him you actually think he
has the highest potential of any
quarterback in this class and I say that
as like I'm getting a jobber owe tattoo
at some point I'm sure I think Jordan
love if he hits his ceiling he's going
to be like you said he's going to be an
exceptional quarterback because that
means he has stopped throwing
interceptions and you're getting all the
talent that comes with the arm strength
and the mobility but if he doesn't he's
the worst quarterback out of the top six
or seven in this class
that's that's the concern so I would not
draft him in the top 15 he's probably
gonna be a very good quarterback that
throws a lot of interceptions but he's
also probably gonna throw a lot of
touchdowns - yeah I mean isn't gonna be
a Jameis where he's 34 30 I was just
gonna say is he famous he's a little
more mobile and he can take an uber so I
know I'm gonna draft him in the top 15
all right third draft of draft question
from HC 41 Connor you're gonna love this
could you see Todd Bowles and the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers trade for Jamal Adams if
the top tackles are gone at 14 overall I
love it I am so here for it I would not
give up the 14th pick for a strong
saftey whose contract is up after the
year there's my take I agree
I love Jamal Adams I think that he can
come in and change your defense and
obviously he's worked with poles before
I think the 14th pick is a little bit
rich for a box safety who is very good
bro I'm not trading off that pic even if
all the tackles are gone I'm probably
still gonna look at other needs not I
wouldn't do it too rich for me I would
be surprised that the Bucks did this I
know Todd Bowles loves Jamal Adams
obviously a great relationship there but
ma'am
a top 15 pick and I'm sure you'd get
something else thrown in there the Jets
have a lot of holes guys they have a lot
of holes if you're telling me they
walked out of this draft with I don't
know Andrew Thomas and CD lamb or Henry
rugs a little nervous to say it but it's
something to think about
yeah and like from the Jets perspective
I would do it like if I was a bum Jo
Douglas yes absolutely because outlined
you can take C D lamb at 11 and a tackle
at 14 and you're fine you're in great
shape from the Bucks that's a little bit
rich for me to be and again I love Jamal
he's an all-pro for a reason hell of a
player I just I don't think the contract
is the biggest part we've seen a lot of
guys get training now and they don't
have that contract
this is Jalen Ramsey I just don't know
if I want to tie up a lot of money to
that kind of safety I mean the Chiefs do
it with Tyrann Mathieu it works I don't
know if it works for a lot of teams yeah
we'll see it's gonna be fun Thursday
night's gonna be wild don't forget make
sure your be our app is updated so you
watch the livestream of our draft
coverage Thursday night Friday night and
Saturday for rounds four and five and
then Connor and I will be grading every
team's draft after the fact so that
police report app is going to be your
Bible and your best friend for draft
week don't forget follow us on Twitter
at stick to football you can find us in
the Bleacher Report app and listen
wherever you get your shows from ello
and Connor this is Matt and we will see
you all Wednesday that's our new
schedule we'll be back Wednesday right
here 5 p.m. Eastern Time
[Music]
[Music]